light has three properties we talked
about the three properties the intensity
the brightness of the light we talked
about the color of the light or its
Spectrum well the third and least known
of properties of light because our eyes
aren't sensitive to it is the a
polarization state of light turns angle
of travel essentially it's the
oscillation if light's a wave like you
and I holding a rope and oscillating a
rope up and down it's the plane that the
Rope is oscillating in it could be
horizontal it could be vertical it could
be any angle between it turns out that
gravitational waves have a beautiful
propensity to turn the polarization of
the microwave background in a very
particular orientation and we can by
mapping the orientation of the microwave
background and its polarization we can
Define the existence or lack thereof
waves of gravity called gravitational
radiation and if detected that doesn't
prove a theory that we can get into
called inflation which is the most
popular a cosmogenesis model that we
have but it gives very very very strong
circumstantial evidence for it but again
I I'm an experimentalist so what do I do
Jordan I try to kill other theories well
it turns out our good friend Roger
Penrose he has a theory that there
should be no polarization of this kind
in other words my team and I observe
this particular polarization
configuration it doesn't prove somebody
right it proves Roger wrong it proves
other colleagues wrong as well that have
alternative hypotheses and what are
those alternative hypotheses well
they're very fascinating because they do
not involve inflation but they also do
not involve a singularity at the origin
of time there is no origin of time